pendant laquelle au début du confinement
donc les forces de l're de l'ordre
pardon en France ont uvré sans masque
alors vous avez dit que il y avait la
même problématique dans d'autres pays
vous avez cité l'Allemagne mais je pense
sincèrement que l'immense majorité de
vos collègues entre
guillemets bénéficiit de masque on
voyait tous les soirs les images en Inde
en Chine un peu partout les forces de
l'ordre étaient masquées et je me
souviens moi d'image qui va qui m'avait
marqué euh à la frontière espagnole on
avait les policiers français alors il y
avait des doigners mais il y avait aussi
des des des policiers qui n'étaient pas
masqué et qui étaient très mécontent en
montrant leurs collègues de l'autre côté
de la frontière la Guardia civile qui
elle était masquée alors euh ça pose
vraiment question bon vous l'avez vous
avez parlé de doctrine vous avez euh
revendiqué le fait de reverser c'était
le terme de Laurent nugz 1400000 masques
FFP2 aux ARS mais euh vous avez mis en
danger vos hommes vous avez mis en
danger madame Préville la aussi fait
remarquer
les personnes qui ont été contrôlées à
qui ont donné ou on prenait un papier
sans qu'il y ait de protection il faut
en être concient alors je sais pas si
c'était la bonne doctrine mais c'est un
fait vous avez dit tout à l'heure euh
vous n'en êtes pas sûr mais qu'il y a
pas une mort parmi les forces de l'ordre
du au avus il semblerait que pardon je
vous
coupe dans le cadre de contrôle il y a
eu à ma connaissance trois morts du
coronavirus dans No service pour des
gens qui n'étaient pas en responsabilité
de terrain et qui n'étaient pas sur le
contrôle le temps de répondre finissons
Olivier Paco à la parole merci mais
effectivement je je suis content de
votre précision parce que moi j'avais
entendu qu'il y avait quand même des
morts parmi les les forces de l'ordre
mais justement avez-vous des
statistiques précises concernant les
forces de l'ordre qui ont été touchées
qui ont été plus ou moins fortement
touché dans mon département dans mon
canton le canton de moui il y a deux
gendarmerie il y en a une qui a été
fermée carrément fermée ce qui est
rarissime parce qu'il y avait une
dizaine de gendarmes qui étaient sur le
flanc